in nordrhein westfälischen bochum gibt
es diese neue aussichtsplattform 32
stufen führen auf das plateau und oben
angekommen hat man einen großartigen
ausblick auf autos straßen staus
untermalt von einem infernalischen
verkehrs lahm
immerhin 58.000 euro hat sich der
landesbetrieb straßen nrw
dieses schmuckstück an der a40 kosten
lassen
da geht können dahin geht dass schimpft
drüber machen die dafür wofür gegen die
eine lachnummer kommt kann dahin scheiße
ganz ehrlich gesagt ganz krasse wege im
proporz zu sagen ich möchte auch nicht
auf autobahnen gucken weil das
interessiert mich nicht was wenn stau
das ist und so also ich weiß nicht wer
sich das angucken soll das autobahnkreuz
bochum west wurde in den vergangenen
jahren für 90 millionen euro umgebaut
als i-tüpfelchen kommt schließlich auch
noch diese aussichtsplattform hinzu
allerdings kann man das gute stück nur
sehr beschwerlicher reichen
es liegt direkt am 5 spurigen
autobahnzubringer parkplätze fehlanzeige
ein bisschen übertrieben halten die
leute die müssen erst mal hinkommen
das ist ja das ist ja was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben für den landesbetrieb
straßen nrw steht die plattform genau an
der richtigen stelle von
geldverschwendung könne keine rede sein
schriftlich heißt es um auch straßenraum
erlebbar zu machen ist darum an diesem
knotenpunkt eine plattform errichtet
worden die einen sicheren überblick über
die unterschiedlichen verkehrsströme
ermöglicht und dabei auch die gestaltung
des dreiecks sichtbar macht
bei soviel straßenplaner prosa schlagen
die menschen in bochum nur noch die
hände über dem kopf zusammen
ich war jeden tag die a40 hin und zurück
von arbeit nach hause und ich habe
wirklich kein interesse irgendwie die a
40 mal von oben anzuschauen und deswegen
kann ich das nicht nachvollziehen werden
gebaut wurde um vornehmlich für das geld
das geld hätte man spenden können wäre
sinnvoller gewesen als er einen
nichtsnutzige aussicht
plattform vielleicht planen sie einfach
ihren osterausflug zur plattform am
bochumer westkreuz unser tipps parken
sie im stadtteil hammer und laufen dann
den halben kilometer zum stau gucken auf
der a40
vielleicht haben sie aber auch was
besseres vor